let's transition now from the house to
the Senate in the Senate exactly as I
predicted
Republicans maintain control and gain
seats officially right now Republicans
are plus two in the Senate but there are
still some races in limbo by the time
you hear this and or watch this maybe by
by tomorrow's program that number will
actually have grown to three or even
possibly four so the results in line
generally with the polling in line with
my prediction yesterday that Democrats
would take over the house that Democrats
would make gains in terms of governors
and that Democrats would not regain
control of the Senate that's exactly
what we are seeing
notable races in the Senate beta
O'Rourke right beta O'Rourke losing to
Ted Cruz in Texas by 2.6 percent do we
say that this was just a loss because
bado lost or do we say you know losing
by only 2.6 percent as a Democrat to an
incumbent Texas Republican senator
that's actually not that bad I don't
know guess it depends whether you're
sort of like a glass half-full or
half-empty type of person in Arizona
Kyrsten Sinema was defeated by
republican martha mcsalley by under one
percentage point that was a
disappointment Bill Nelson versus Rick
Scott in Florida Scott won by 0.4
percent very disappointing Bill Nelson
already calling for a recount there I
sometimes get the feeling that in
Florida you could have a serial killer
versus someone else and the serial
killer could be the Democrat or the
Republican quite frankly and it would
sort of be closed because it just seems
to always be that way in the state of
Florida and unfortunately as of as of
right now pending a recount that changes
the results that one did not go our way
and a really big win for Democrats is
Jackie Rosen in Nevada
she was running against incumbent
Republican senator Dean Heller
she won hugely by five percent and that
is the Democratic plus one
then otherwise we have Republican wins
Republicans picking up North Dakota
where Heidi Heitkamp lost incumbent
Democrat huge loss by 11 I mean that
that is a race we're going to have to
analyze in more detail by itself because
it is just such a disaster for the
Democratic Party and the playing
politics in calculating what exactly
should she and shouldn't she say about
Brett Kavanaugh when that was going I
mean just everything that is horrible
about national politics was reflected in
Heidi Heitkamp race and eventual loss in
North Dakota in Indiana we had incumbent
Democratic senator Joe calling it
Connelly he lost hugely to Republican
challenger Mike Braun by almost 10
points it is Indiana but it's still
embarrassing when the incumbent loses
that bad and then in Missouri we saw
incumbent Democratic Senator Claire
McCaskill just completely fail and lose
by 6 points to Republican Josh Holley
who will take over there so again so far
for what's official as of literally this
moment Democrats picked one up
Republicans picked up three that's plus
two for Republicans and we are
anticipating that there's going to be a
little more for Republicans either way
they won't have a supermajority but they
will maintain a majority and it will be
slightly bigger important data point for
the popular vote okay
in Senate races yesterday Democrats
received 12 million more votes than
Republicans okay
in California in Feinstein versus Kevin
de Leon you had two Democrats so when
you've got Democrats running against
each other that gives you more
Democratic votes the Leon got 2.7
million votes so even if we take those
out Democrats in Senate elections still
won the popular vote by 10 million votes
yesterday this is just sort of the
basics of how population distribution
works against Democrats 10 10 to 12
million more votes but lost seats and
that is another issue that is sort of a
systemic issue that we've spoke
about for a very very long time so not
to Pat myself on the back because I just
said I think what the polls suggest is
going to be what happens many in the
audience with the same prediction
Democrats take the House Republicans
take the Senate and after the break what
I'm going to dig into are the political
implications and so much more about what
this means and it's not all great for
Democrats and the left as you can
probably imagine send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show major
major program today one of today's
sponsors is Skillshare which is an
incredible online learning community
offering over 10,000 high-quality online
courses on a huge variety of topics
first 500 who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class that Skillshare offers you'll have
free access to courses on music art
photography business computer
programming cooking meditation and
everything in between
I think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than 10 bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of skill
share but hurry it's only available to
the first 500 who sign up